because of the parts you've played and
the parts i know you from on tv like
when married with children and stuff
i always thought that you were like this
chick who grew up like maybe in the
midwest or the south or something but
your dad was a famous like
a pretty successful director yeah you're
a showbiz family yeah
yeah yeah yeah what did he direct he
directed
all early television dr kildaran peter
gunn man from uncle
man from uncle did you go to the set
with him i did that was sort of like
you know my uh i would go i would make
friends that way i'd bring them down to
the set because i was kind of shy
and wasn't that the coolest work
environment to go to upset
and see that being shot it was pretty
cool i actually met elvis presley that
way too because he did an elvis presley
movie
which one girl happy and how old were
you when you met elvis i think i was
around 12.
when you have a dad like that right it
becomes your burning desire to become an
actress
oh not at all no in fact i you know i i
wanted to be when i grew up a
singer-songwriter which was
he he sort of was not very on board with
that even though i was pretty good
you were real good and when you tell
your dad you're going to be a singer
he's disappointed in you he wanted you
to be an actress
well i think now that i have my own
children i understand where he was
coming from he wanted me to have
medical benefits right he knew he could
get me a union card you know he was like
here no be
in this television show he put me in a
show called columbo
when i was 18 17 16 something so that i
would get a union card
and i think he knew i was going to go
into show business
so he just wanted to read me i mean the
fact that at the time i didn't think it
was so sweet i thought he was really not
letting me
you know do your thing do my thing and i
was mad at him
but i mean imagine a dad who says hey
i'm going to put you in colombo i mean
i think he thought i was a good actor
and you know i was in the
high school plays and i thought well she
can do this so and he sent me to
i wanted to go to a music college and he
he wouldn't let me be in the music
department
he said if you can be in the if you can
audition and get in the theater
department i'll pay for you to go there
so i did
but what's amazing is you actually had
success as a
you were a backup singer yes and you
sang for bob dylan
yes and you sang for bette midler yes
etta james
eddie james that's a real legitimate
singer what can a background singer make
a year i mean
honestly yeah it wasn't it wasn't great
that way how do you get paid like when
dylan hires you
and where did you meet dylan to hire bob
this is my dylan story
so i was i had this friend of mine i was
in a band with and there were
three girls in the band and she knew bob
dylan because she used to go hang out at
his house up in malibu and he said
come down to the rehearsal bring some
singers so she brought me i mean i
literally
he never even heard me so he hired me
and when you walk in and you see bob
dylan standing there yeah i was a little
freaked out i was 19.
right 19 and were you confident i mean
did you say to yourself i can nail this
i can get this job
i i don't know i mean i was confident as
a singer so i just i think i was just
kind of going along with it but when you
audition for dylan how does that go down
you're standing there he says okay let's
do balloon in the wind and then you
stand in the
and really so what song did you sing
with bob dylan the only ones i really
remember was just like a woman
uh wow then nobody feels any pain
that's right yeah right and then um uh
there were a couple you know i don't
even
it was it was kind of a blur did you
sing on the records
no no no no i worked with him for two
months two months
two months i i rehearsed with him before
a tour i always put it on my resume
though because it was
it was it was freaking awesome right and
then uh
you know why two months though i mean
because he fired me
do you have any idea why you were fired
well no i don't i i mean in my mind it's
because i
i'm sure i was doing a terrible job i
was so intimidated
you know this is what would happen we
would rehearse and then we'd sit in a
room and he'd play the tape back
like from rehearsing so if you made a
mistake he wouldn't really like say
anything he'd just look at you
and you just like this big
so that was a little intimidating of
course weren't you like on one of those
mary tyler moore shows but not that it
was
not the uh the big one though yeah i was
on the one after the big one great
was that your big break as an actress on
television
yeah it was my first sitcom and they you
were acting in plays and somebody
spotted you and put you on the married
tyler marshall yes
yes and yes and i and my part was
i played this like hardcore reporter and
i'd smoke cigarettes and blow smoke in
mary's face and then do you get married
with children
right i did like six months after that
you have to audition for that
i did wasn't the original vision for
married with children
that it was going to be a big plump
dumpy yeah housewife well i
read the scripture and i thought these
people speak horribly to each other they
must have great sex i mean something has
to keep them together so
at the end of the day so and i just
dolled her up i just went in
looking that way i sort of you know wore
tight clothes she always seemed too good
for him
i mean to me there were always a couple
that got married very young
and then there was no option about
getting out you know for financial
reasons for
you know it's just not what you do i
mean i think there's a lot of people
like that
i remember uh when that show came on the
air the fox network was brand new
right the only shows they had were
married with children in the simpsons
right and married with children was a
real unexpected hit i think people
thought that was going to be off after
two episodes
right they were just like they tried to
take it off the air but there was one
woman named terry ricolta that caused
this big stir
that got us on the cover the new york
times and tripled our ratings right yeah
but she tried to get us off because her
kids she want her kid to watch it
you know when our response was like you
know just change the channel it was all
this censorship
[ __ ] you know it was like no so i
know something about that
yeah i'm sure you do so our response was
or the producer's response i was just a
hired gun
was you know we're not you know go away
so she boosted our ratings we ended up
sending her flowers every year with a
big thank you card
you